hating gang member to finding Islam
Islam continues to attract people from
around the globe both men and women have
joined the fold of Islam in huge numbers
in recent years in this video
we will be shedding some light on the
story of one such British Muslim convert
named Chris who finally decided to
become a Muslim
so let's begin his fascinating story
so to begin with
Chris grew up in a Pakistani
neighborhood of the United Kingdom from
the very beginning he knew that there
had to be a god
who created the whole universe even
though he didn't believe that God was
Jesus he started going to church
regularly at the age of nine
meanwhile in school he was an
enthusiastic rugby player as he got
older his hatred for pakistanis and
Muslims in general began to grow
by the time he turned 17 he stopped
going to church as well instead he would
now spend his time in a pub the pubs are
fun there he would meet people who would
support his islamophobic ideas
so he obviously felt validated
furthermore at that time he had started
watching documentaries on Middle Eastern
countries and how the people there was
suffering under their so-called Muslim
rulers huh interesting so far I mean
when you when you have like a hateful
ideology and all you know you're with
people that have the same views and
don't differ you just get sucked into a
vacuum of your stupid your stupid ideas
this happens all the time leftists only
talked to leftists right people only
talk to Red people and they're just like
yeah
yeah watching those documentaries
triggered his patriotism and he vowed
that he would never let that happen to
his country
ultimately soon enough
he decided to join the English Defense
League what is that an organization made
in the name of Auntie okay stop so and
immediately hear this video started with
people were joining in droves okay this
is an advertisement this started with
people were joining in droves men and
women and that's fine like I'm there's
nothing harmful here so far like I just
want to be clear that this is an
advertisement so I'm looking at every
line in here as that and what he said is
he started to become patriotic and then
the next sentence is that he joined you
know this basically right wing you know
looks like based on this picture if it's
even a real picture you know a bunch of
nut jobs who are you know hateful and it
Associates patriotism and they do this
in the United States all the time it
Associates patriotism with hatred and
that is disgusting to me because it is
absolutely not true we watched a video
with Logan Paul a little while ago where
he Associated racism and homophobia with
Christianity you're a racist homophobic
Christian don't be making those
associated so I'm seeing this in this
video already and I want to point it out
and we all have to be watching these
videos and you especially my child need
to be watching these videos not just
getting sucked in because it's all
propaganda another important thing to
mention here is that Chris hadn't shared
his islamophobic thoughts with his
parents
especially his mother who happened to be
strictly against any sort of racism
so there was absolutely no one to guide
him to take a step back from that
radicalization and he was going only one
way there was nothing to gain the path
of hatred however Chris remained curious
about God and Muhammad peace be upon him
so he kept asking people that he would
meet about them but they kept dishing
him off unfortunately he didn't ask
those questions to Muslims as he didn't
trust them enough
ultimately after four years Chris felt
like he had no purpose in life and he
quit the English Defense League it was
during his time in the English Defense
League that he made his two friends whom
he later found out to be Muslims they
were actually pretty nice people and
Chris fat guy looks like Ben Shapiro ah
yeah little Ben how cute find it hard to
believe that they were Muslims moving on
after leaving the English Defense League
Chris found himself in a bad phase as he
got into drug dealing the only good
thing that came out of that part
of Chris's life was he made an
acquaintance with a Pakistani Taxi
Driver whom he would use to call for all
his movements in and around the city
this made him realize that pakistanis
are actually not that bad and that they
can be trusted anyhow when Chris finally
isn't that like crazy that some people
like genuinely think of like an entire
group of people as one way it's like I
met one good Pakistani and it's like
they can be good it's like you thought a
hundred percent of a group of people who
were bad and there wasn't like some that
would be nice like that that's
surprising to you like and it's so funny
because it's so contradictory though to
um people's personal experiences you
think they would learn from them so say
I love you sometimes you do things that
I don't like as your mother and let's
say you did okay imagine an imaginary
situation I still see the whole picture
of you and I don't look at the one bad
thing forever all day and night you know
and but that is also true of groups of
people and you you have to look at
people as individuals and so we're so
brain people are so easy to buy into the
Matrix programming and the media and
there's hate everybody those people
those people are against you those
people are all racist and homophobes and
and xenophobes and they put these labels
on and it's just gotten to the point
where you know nobody can think for
themselves and really look at people
one-on-one and so that it becomes a
story so exceptional that we have to do
a video about it because Chris met a
friend who he liked and oh my God found
out he was a Muslim later it's
ridiculous that this is some exception
that we have to talk about it that's
life stop being a judgmental [ __ ]
before you meet people only gave up drug
dealing exhausting he couldn't overcome
the drug addiction that came with it he
would consume cocaine and alcohol
regularly just to stay saturated due to
that drug addiction Chris got into a car
crash and eventually ended up in a
hospital where according to his own
words he died two times meaning that his
heart stopped beating a couple of times
however the doctors and nurses treated
him well and he got better over time he
later found out that some of the nurses
who tended to him were pakistanis so he
came to the conclusion that pakistanis
were after all just like other people in
any case it was too soon
after all he thought of Muslims as
extremists and hated them all his life
proceeding ahead after Chris's Discovery
he decided to give Christianity another
chance he went through the Bible again
but came to the conclusion that Jesus is
a prophet not God
so who was God Chris's research
continued which ultimately led him to
discover one of the biggest Muslim
YouTube channels it is worth mentioning
that Chris with all due respect to Chris
there's no way that this guy came to the
conclusion that Jesus was a prophet not
God if he really read the Bible that
carefully first of all second of all
someone else came to that conclusion and
convinced him of it this is just a story
being told by someone with an agenda and
nothing against Islam if somebody comes
to that and it makes their life better I
am all for it like I said to the three
Muslims I'd love to see us all just like
or maybe it was Ollie but yeah Ali dawa
but you know I really it would love to
see people come to one or the other
because I think in the end if you really
embrace it it really helps you to live
or you know clean your life and a Kinder
life so nothing against it but why in
everything Islam that we all these Islam
Pro Islam videos do they have to take a
moment to [ __ ] on Christianity and all
the Christian things that I'm delving
into they don't crap on other religions
and that that's a distinction that I've
clearly noticed don't have to [ __ ] on
this and if this is good it should be
self-evident just saying this does kind
of seem like an advertisement I'm not
gonna lie it does and it's and and
there's a couple of anti-christian
messages which I don't if your thing's
that good if my if I'm selling vodka and
it's the best vodka I don't even have to
mention the other vodkas I'm not gonna
be like it's better than Tito's is
better than Gray Goose or whatever like
you know what I'm saying I don't know I
don't like it I don't I don't like it
and I say that about the feminists
you're so great why are you even going
to mention men just keep going we'll
find out you'll be you'll you'll show us
yourselves but they gotta step on a
white man's neck in order to stand a
little taller that I don't like and
that's what I'm seeing here well the
thing that I was saying is like I agree
like it just sounds a little sus that he
just like read the Bible and like with
his self-analysis he was like it seems
like Jesus is a prophet not God while
reading the Bible it's like that's oh
right that was my second point that
seems like it's this guy seems like he
was a little bit of a half-wind his
whole life and all of a sudden he's he's
he's a theologian okay let's go it's a
Muslim Channel at the time instead he
thought he would was watching stuff
about Christianity anyway he kept
watching videos from that channel and he
felt as if he had finally found a
resource that made sense that filled him
up with Euphoria he felt like this was
his cue to go back to Christianity
meanwhile Chris worked in different
positions and that is when he met a guy
named Bashir Bashir
was a very well-mannered and kind person
who quickly became friends with Chris
the two of them started hanging out
quite often at one time they were
sitting in a restaurant Bashir asked the
waiter if they serve halal food Chris
was taken aback by this and that was
when he came to know that Bashir was a
Muslim it was at this point that Chris
realized how wrong he has been to judge
Muslims based on their religion he had
never given any Muslim a chance and
assumed that they were bad soon after
that Chris found out that the YouTube
channel that he was watching for two
months now was actually about Islam
[ __ ] Christianity I call [ __ ]
every time they say Muhammad they say
peace be to his name every time there's
all like there was two months there are
two months of watching a YouTube channel
and you're just figuring it out so that
proves that if that all right there's
either two things one this is nonsense
or two he was a halfway in which case
his analysis about Jesus just being a
prophet
I agree this is a silly video and and
this is actually I think like hurting
the religion because it seemed like
there's more stuff with like an agenda
behind it not just being like pure I I
kind of agree with you here yeah
we love our Muslim friends we love
talking about it we like we've been
having such a good time exploring the
the difference is in understanding it
this just it seems like it was written
in a room with a script and and due to
his drug dealing he got into a car crash
it's like read by Aroma read by a robot
it doesn't even see it this seems like
an AI voice not even a real voice I
wonder what the people have to say in
the comments is this on a famous Channel
like what is this nonsense oh yeah
pretty pretty famous Muslim convert
stories watching it only to come back to
it a month later this time around he
watched all the videos with a clear mind
he got to know about Allah the prophet
Muhammad so all of a sudden the videos I
talked about a law the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him all of a sudden they
were obvious Muslim videos but what was
this foolishness and everything else
he tried to refute the Islamic ideas but
they resonated with the logic Chris was
also particularly impressed after
reading about the character of the holy
prophet peace be upon him
everything about Islam made sense and
that was what the cool Builders knew
that he didn't want to waste his life go
into a pub and drinking but instead
joined the fold of Islam
moving on Chris told Bashir about his
intention to become a Muslim you know
this might be based off of a true story
too and then they just took the script
and made it sound weird
consequently Chris went to the Imam in a
mosque and set his shahada in 2016.
Chris shahada was filmed live after
Chris said his shahada around 50 Muslim
Brothers in the mosque came to hug him
and offered to take him out for a meal
and of course Chris was surprised to see
such love from the people he hated for
the better part of his life
anyhow he went out of the mosque he got
a call from his mother who told him that
she had watched the live filming of him
becoming a Muslim luckily though she was
supportive of Chris's decision and so
were his other family members
to all non-muslims out there Chris now
32 invites them to look at Islam with an
open mind and not have any bias against
the said religion
besides being a devoted Muslim brother
Chris is an aspiring strong man and his
ambition is to become the best in the
business
may Allah help brother Chris in all his
Ambitions and goals I mean
maybe we should also watch the actual
video of this young man talking Chris
what was it skill something skill hold
like maybe maybe we should watch that
because that video made him seem like he
was a half wit his whole life let's not
brag about bringing in the half wits oh
yeah that's that's definitely one of the
more interesting videos wasn't like a
typical one you think that was one of
the more interesting no like like we
have different thoughts on it I mean not
yeah you're right it wasn't one of the
more interesting ones it felt like there
was a clear agenda and it was written by
a script I mean
I promise if you want us to watch the
like the original Dude talking about his
story it gave yeah let's do it that way
if you want to hear us you know somebody
sent us a link but like interesting in
the fact you know that it created a
reaction between us but nothing has been
more interesting than the real con the
high quality videos about Islam that
we've where we've learned something or
the real world
yeah the conversations we've gotten into
where where our hearts have been changed
not for me necessarily that I want to
become a Muslim but in the fact that my
heart has been changed in understanding
their religion and and my mind has been
changed about what it's all about and I
love that I love learning new things
this I just felt like if I was 12 it
might have had an influence on me but I
just feel like that was just some goofy
propaganda make sure to watch better
videos in the future thank you guys so
much for watching make sure to like
subscribe join my Discord I think
there's value in watching that video
though because it's value and talking
about the quality of the information
we're taking in okay yeah do that what
he said that's all thanks for watching
follow me on Instagram at Sunny Fez are
you guys gonna miss our Christmas
background because I'm gonna miss it I
love Christmas
won't last long yeah the feelings